dusk in the village of Farah Coe school
ended many hours ago but the children
don't want to go home this is where they
can comfortably get their homework done
in the evening the village doesn't have
any electricity but the school now has
these lights they were installed here
just recently we are very happy that we
have lights now we can study here and
after dinner we can come back here to
play the energy for the school comes
from solar power engineer ma Canton
Deena is responsible for the project
after studying in France he decided to
bring his expertise back home he could
have taken his career a long way in
Europe but he's happy to be back in Mali
this is my baby even if I didn't finance
it it's my baby I'm so excited that this
project succeeded and that I was
involved from the beginning to the end
every time I see it I'm really happy I
feel my time on this earth was
worthwhile unity makan has to regularly
check the system to ensure that it works
properly
his first major contract came from the
local municipality this school has a
small solar power substation that keeps
the lights on the energy from the Sun is
stored in these batteries it's a huge
advance for the poverty-stricken village
after making sure everything is in order
tangina heads back to the capital Bamako
it takes him half a day to get there
today he's lucky the ferry is fully
operational the day when the solar power
plant was delivered was a different
matter the last time we came to install
the equipment we had to use canoes and
then bring them back it took us a long
time and was really tiring but that's
part of our work we are rural people and
it's not easy to get to the remote
villages we see in Rania makan comes
from Timbuktu in northern Mali he
understands very well potential benefits
of the scorching Sun at his office he's
always busy talking to suppliers writing
quotes and discussing his latest
projects with business contacts his
phone is never quiet energy is life it's
a source of life it's important like
water or light life here in Farah Co has
drastically changed the extra study time
in the evenings has started to pay off
in their last exams the students here
had the highest grades in the whole
community